all right let's go
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
your favorite podcast
you know what we do
[Music]
you know the names
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
riverwood griffin and we back with a
guest
i got a fabulous guest i can't wait for
you to hear the interview i love this
guy a lot uh mr
anomaly hip-hop artist um
political activist
just a great source of information agree
with or disagree i like how he presents
his information so i have him on the
podcast
over zoom
so uh that's pretty it's a good one i
really enjoyed this but once again just
everybody welcome back to
real favorites
[Music]
yes riffing with griffin
riverwood griffin is brought to you by
ritual we deserve to know what we're
putting in our bodies and why ritual
volte vitamins are delivered to your
door every month with key ingredients
your body needs ritual is offering my
listeners 10 off during your first three
months visit ritual.com griffin to start
your ritual today
all right big shout out today to helix
sleep take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to the mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life find your perfect mattress at
helixsleep.com griffin okay so ladies
and gentlemen uh welcome to uh special
riffing with griffin
um
i have a guest and we're via zoom right
now
we'll find out
all about him but i'm actually a huge
fan um let's see let me let me go down
it hip hop artist
uh common sense connoisseur
uh political activist is that is that a
correct uh
hey whatever you want yeah at this point
i'm like i always say i'm not an
activist but i guess technically you
know i could how about this how about
this you're actively political right
it's all good yeah mr anomaly thank you
sir for being on we're from with griffin
um thank you yeah man like i'm actually
like i was saying like you know before
we started recording i was like man i'm
actually a huge fan of yours even though
we're not necessarily in the same space
politically
but like i often look at your videos and
it often gives me like a uh like i go oh
okay i didn't think of it that way or
you know it either it either strengthens
how i already feel or it gives me
something else to think about and i
really
enjoy that about what you do you know
appreciate that yeah i think that's what
it's about too is challenging your ideas
and you know hearing it from both sides
and sometimes for different countries
different groups of people etc people
have valid perspective you know there's
that one meme i remember it's like
someone's looking at the number the one
way someone's on the other side and
they're seeing different things so i
think it's you know it's good to
challenge yourself which a lot of people
try not to do i think nowadays it's easy
to stray away from that on both sides
yeah man for sure i mean i i i totally
i totally agree with you i feel like
it's like it's like we can't
it's like we can't agree to disagree
it's like it either has to be agree with
me and everything you say is terrible as
a and how can people live like that you
know i just i don't know
it's a terrible space to be in and i
think that that's like prevalent in our
country right now or just when in terms
of like social media and and how we
interact with each other it's very all
or nothing
yeah i think things have definitely
gotten more um certain people have
gotten more sensitive but also people
can find their own kind of crew and
crowd online so it's easy to uh you know
just find people who agree with you for
for everybody i have a question real
quick i don't want to interfere but it
took me off the screen i don't know if
that's going to mess with the recording
don't matter no no no because i wanted
you to see me okay um yeah i wanted you
to see because like
i want i want you to see the full me
you're like you gotta yeah yeah yeah
because it was like
so we can talk like yeah yeah yeah this
is just some this is behind the scenes
technical part of roofing with
girlfriend
just to show me the full you like like i
said you're a tall guy so you're like
you know if you disagree with me too
hard remember i'm not this little figure
on the side of the screen i'm the real
deal so
i know it's you know it isn't isn't it
strange how people like when they when
they see you in person like you know
i've been on tv for a while you know i
was at workaholics i was all these
things and then like i'm doing stand-up
and then people walk up to me and
they're like whoa bro i didn't know you
were this tall you're way bigger in
person and you just kind of like
i mean
i feel like ideas are the same way you
know what i mean it's like when you get
with somebody in person and you it's
like it's a totally different
interaction that people have with you
when they go like oh wow because you're
a tall guy too right you're uh yeah i'm
like six two six three and uh same thing
i'm always sitting down though there's
more right exactly you standing up so
people should have known maybe but it's
uh with ideas too i think when you're
talking online even myself i think on
twitter it's easy to just type things
right you can say whatever you want
whenever you want but if you're standing
face to face with the person uh you know
it's definitely different i think that's
why podcasts have really taken off too
it's like long-form people having
discussions that you know a lot of
people are chirpy online uh but then
when you have maybe the counter idea or
someone else there it's totally
different energy totally different uh
feeling
for sure how long so how long have you
had the hair how long is that how long
is
it
years with the long hair but when i
started rapping when i was 18 or 19 on
youtube it started getting pretty big
couple million views when i was like 19
just freestyling the little wayne beats
and i had like the bieber like beatles
haircut i thought it was the beatles
like i thought i was cool like the
beatles and then bieber came and then
everyone's like you look like bieber you
look like bieber and so my hair was
always sort of the thing but it was it
was never like a fashion statement i
just didn't know who i was and i didn't
know how to cut it you know like i
didn't have life experience to figure
out different ways to put it so for
certain people they thought it was like
a real statement but i was just kind of
like smoking too much weed and just like
if it grows it grows you know that was
kind of my whole thought on it it's kind
of similar so so why keep why are you
keeping it now is it just like is it out
of pride or are you just like you know
like because i feel like are you the
kind of person you're like people are
like man cut your hair and you're like
no nobody tells me to cut my hair
long
no no i don't care i think i'll cut it
eventually but it's kind of just it's
been this way for a while and it's
comfortable but it kind of like with my
facial hair like i do the same thing
every couple months i grow it out and
then i cut it when i and i shave it all
the way off like i don't just keep it
but every time i do it people say oh you
look better with the shape you look
better with with with the mustache so
anytime you're kind of changing styles
you're always going to have people who
like like if i cut my hair a bunch of
people were like oh look so much better
this way so i'm going to be like oh you
look terrible like you should have kept
it long that you know so you can never
win i i don't care i think that's my
superpowers like to me it just it is
what it is i like to like body surf hang
out i'm not it's not like a whole part
of my identity i guess it's just like
comfortable like say you know your
mustache like you know it's like yeah i
don't know yeah
yeah and i just you know i grew this
like a pandemic beard
and then once like you know because like
the pandemic hit and i was like oh man
and then you're just like okay why am i
shaving or why am i doing this and i
like so one day i shaved my face like
shaved everything off and i looked crazy
like a crazy person and then and then
the next time i grew this beard and then
now i grew the beard and everybody was
like oh i kind of like that and now i
look at my face and i feel like i should
have always had a beard you know what i
mean and so it's just like you know it
just this is how that sort of like
shaped our our new world right now like
how we're all different you know what i
mean did you see when when the pandemic
first hit they were telling people to
shave they were like yo coronavirus
could stick on your beard like you
should shave it all off and you had you
got the hipsters in brooklyn they have
like the long ones they're like you know
they're choosing between life or death
here they're like do i you know i want
to look fly
but that's all you know what and that's
all part of the misinformation that
we'll get into but like you know i just
i do i don't want it to all be like you
know
because it's because like i tend to like
get heavy all the time and i and i watch
you so i know
a lot of the things i see of you you get
heavy too but you know there is this
music side of you and it's like like you
said you were
doing freestyles and rapping uh since
you've been a a youngster so like like
what was uh what what what started that
you know what i mean because you know
it's always like
you know it's like always when like you
know someone non-black starts rapping
you know
there's always that stigma
you know
so like what was your influences what
what made you get into it and were you
thinking about that at all
considering how thoughtful you are about
everything else i'm about to make myself
whiter it was a shell silver scenes
where the sidewalk hands like the
rhyming poems when i was a kid that kind
of required me to rhyme so i'm gonna
take it to a whole new level of
whiteness but uh
and then it was like eminem
[Laughter]
eminem and dr dre i heard them rhyming
real fast i forgot about dre and i was
like wow that's rhyming poetry on
steroids so i always loved poetry and
rhyming and i started freestyling
writing raps since like seventh grade
um but the stigma about like you know
being white and rap i never minded it
because to me i was like i you know i'm
not one of these guys who just comes
here and like yo i deserve it like i
wasn't some trap rapper you know just
kind of riding a wave i was always
really good at freestyle so any party i
was at no matter who people were you
know at first they'd be skeptical but
when i lay down freestyle start talking
about things in the room they'd be like
all right that boy is nice so i never
had a problem even with labels and stuff
i had people that were real authentic
jam master jay's family they always
liked me and they always told me like
you know a lot of these other white
dudes like they're trying to be someone
else and they're trying to impress
everybody like you just don't care you
know you're being yourself and we could
feel that so i never mind the stigma but
yeah i was freestyling rhyming since
like
seventh grade
well i think authenticity
always shines through i think our
artistry authenticity no matter who you
are what you are you know you have that
first initial where people go who's this
guy and then after that it's like it's
all on you you know and i think like
eminem has smashed that uh stereotype
you know his whole career right i mean
like i don't think you can have a list
of top five rappers of all time and
eminem is not in that list so it's like
he you know what i mean he's already
crazy his like the way he'd break down
lyrics was crazy his storytelling was
crazy and that's to me that's what it is
like of course there's like a racial
aspect to society everyone feels a
certain way but if you're good enough
everybody likes you like luca donches in
the nba nobody cares that he's white
he's killing it so and that's everybody
and everything is if you're good enough
and you're real enough i think you could
you could break through and people will
be like all right that that person
belongs here yeah well that's good i was
just curious if there's like because i
don't really care i just was asking like
you know because of like you know know
what little i know of you but just but
by by but like you know you think you
know someone because of like what you
see them do on the internet yeah you
know what i mean and i just see you
being like super thoughtful and like
factual all the time so i'm like
do you live your life like that you know
what i'm saying like is are you always
careful are you always like thinking
about uh not being misconstrued is that
something that like what got you to that
point
i used to only rap and i had labels
interested because at the time this
isn't that big now but i had a couple
million views when youtube was first
starting out and they saw my bieber type
haircut and they're like oh this guy
could be something but they always were
like don't talk about politics just talk
about this and they always tried to like
change the narrative of who i was and i
was like ah i never liked it i never
like fell for debate i was reading the
contracts i was smart enough to be like
how are you going to keep 85 like that
don't make sense to me you know like
they had crazy little traps for me so i
never really did it i stayed on my own
dropped out of school had to work like a
lot of struggling but then i just kept
kind of pushing and the political angle
came 2016. i actually was you know more
left leaning at the time i didn't care
about either side but i thought bernie
sanders seemed pretty authentic and i
hated how the media was kind of rigging
it against him like it's over and i felt
kind of cheated i was like listen if she
wins she wins but you're acting like
it's over before it even started and
then i started taking a deep dive into
the media manipulation so that's when i
kind of started pushing back against the
grain and thinking like all right you
know i think i should i should do my own
narrative on this to try to you know get
my perspective so it's not just what
you're seeing in the google searches
oh that's so interesting
2016 um but you know you you
you feel like a forensic detective to me
you know you know what i mean like i
mean honestly man like uh you know i
suggest everybody that's this listening
right now is go check out his page
regardless of your
um political leanings i mean i admire
the the like
you go all right i feel this way and i'm
gonna show you why i feel this way and
you've always had this deep dive it's
very it's very much like you know like
you're like very much like a detective
like where did that come from when did
that start did you what i'm saying is
did you know from the beginning that you
know what if i'm gonna show this i'm
gonna really show it and then see what
happens yeah i guess it comes from like
first of all you know what does
everybody hate in the media whether
you're left wing or right wing you're
perceiving they're lying right they're
lying fox news is lying cnn's lying
right when you're sliding left fingers
are lying so i thought you know yeah
pick up sorry we had a little technical
difficulties but we are back and you
were saying
yeah on the on the part of why i'm so
careful with what i do you know
everybody perceives they don't want
dishonest information or lies you know a
lot of people call themselves truthers
so i was like when i do my reporting i
want to be as honest as i possibly could
be and a lot of people lose sight of
that i think what drives both sides to
really be irrational is they want to win
so bad about what they're talking about
they forget what the original concept
was it's like i want to tell the truth
you know the fake news media is lying
let me be more honest so i really was
careful where i want to be the change i
want to see in the world if i want to
fight lies and misinformation whatever
you know i have to be more honest and
also the fact checker era has made me be
even more careful because i was always
careful but i've had my page demonetized
i've had multiple strikes for things i
didn't do wrong based on either lies
that they said that i said something i
never said or you know you can't
disagree with this government bureaucrat
or else we will you know give you a
striking stuff so i try to be so careful
and say listen where i'm getting my
information from it's not from the dark
web or hn it's literally reuters you
know new york times washington post this
is all mainstream information data so i
try to be very careful like that because
now i was always careful but the
scrutiny is like they're waiting for you
to say something that they i just got a
strike on my youtube channel i'm not
going to repeat what i said but i was
quoting a cnn analyst talking about
cloth masks and she was saying on her
platform about how they weren't the best
you know and i just kind of quoted her
loosely and said something maybe in the
wrong way and they they refused to take
the strike away even though i was
referencing what someone else said so
you got to be very careful in this day
and age they're they're like hawks
waiting for you to question the wrong
thing and they get very upset
yeah it's kind of that's kind of
upsetting to yeah just because you know
you know i i don't know how old you are
but you know
i'm for me like i'm almost 50 years old
so when i was a kid
and we looked at the news
there was a thought that everything on
this was real and true
it was just an assumption that you just
made
which should be the assumption you make
because that's what it should be you
know the news to me is supposed to be a
fourth branch of government it's
supposed to be the thing that puts
everything in check keeps people honest
and then what we come to find out is
that they probably always been skewed
it's probably always had an agenda and
the moment that the 24-hour news cycle
came into play and the fact that there
are commercials on those news
platforms it means that like this is
just commercialized just like anything
else
and so
you know that's very upsetting so then
you just kind of wake up one day and
just be like well where are we supposed
to get our news from that we could go
that's true
and i don't think that there's any news
uh
none of these mainstream ones that the
three letter four letter whatever ones
they don't none of them seem to be none
of them seem to be like you know
giving us
where we can go oh that's true
right and it's all hyper sensationalized
so like for instance you know it's
always like doom and gloom and you know
freaking people out where even when you
tell some really heavy stuff if you were
a good friend you wouldn't tell your
friend like yeah go cry and hate
yourself for five days you'd be like no
it's gonna be okay you know what i'm
saying we're gonna get through this
there's none of that sort of coaching
for these you know authority figures
where you have to understand not
everybody's going to be able to handle
this information even if it really is a
crisis you should be trying to keep
people comfortable and make them feel
good about it so you got all these hyper
sensationalized media freaking everyone
out all the time everything's got to be
the end of the world because if it is
the ratings go up you know and then in
the commercials they're selling whatever
you know depression pills i always found
that correlation interesting it's like
very depressing news and then they're
selling like depressants in in the
commercial section where um you know i
was like yeah if i listen to your news
all the time maybe i would be that
target audience because you guys are
miserable you know and also like uh not
very honest yeah
yeah it's just it's tough man it's a
tough road because it also depends like
i'm sure someone listening might be like
well what's their agenda what and it's
like you know it that's where
i think that when you have it
when you have society in a state where
you can't trust anyone
that's not a good society to that's not
good for information
you know and i think we're at that point
right now we're at that point where like
i don't know where to get any
information from especially when it
comes to this pandemic you know it's
like i want to go like hey where can i
find out this where can i find out you
know what's what's in the vaccine
because i need to know i want what i'd
like to know or hey what what are the
numbers or like what what what about
obesity what about like you know they
don't they seem to like there's nowhere
to like honestly go and be like oh i
know that this is correct and it really
sucks when it it really sucks when you
like you want to go to a place like the
cdc this is like supposed to be the
center for disease control or the who or
the world health organization you would
like to think in your brain if i go to
that website
they're going to tell me the truth right
and
we're set up in a state right now where
you feel like i don't even know if
that's true do they have an agenda too
and it's just like you know i don't know
if i like the state of the the media
right now right what's interesting about
that too is a lot of people will say
because they've heard it so many times
the science is settled you can't
question the science the experts agree
these are like sayings people say if you
listen to the world health organization
which for a while on facebook if you
were to disagree with the world health
organization facebook seemed to have
partnered with them to basically set
your misinformation for disagreeing with
them but the world health organization
came out recently and said we don't
believe at this time it's it makes and
there's any evidence at all for booster
shots and children but the cdc doesn't
say that and there's people advising for
booster shots and children so you have
the center for disease control in the
world health organization disagreeing on
this key issue and this isn't the first
time that they've butted heads in my
opinion that's a good thing that means
that somebody is doing their job and
they're countering the narrative but you
know they're they're pushing this
narrative that you're not allowed to
disagree with the people who disagree
with themselves and you know the media
instead of kind of challenging big
pharma in the government they're kind of
just challenging anybody challenging
them people like joe rogan who if
anybody's listened to him you know he's
not this like partisan hack he's like
you know somebody who's very thoughtful
very good at answering questions and
immediately we'll have on other
perspectives as soon as like oh you're
having too many of these people he'll go
out of his way to go have someone else
like he's had on experts that are in the
biden administration on a show a year
ago like he's not he's not holding one
side from people but what bothers people
is he's showing everything he's doing
what old media used to be and it it's
like people don't want you to challenge
your ideas like you say why you like my
page that's how i've learned so much
people are trying to pretty much
eliminate that and be like this is it
don't look anywhere else and that's not
healthy or honest
yeah it's not healthy i i agree with you
and it's like but i feel like the the
the stigma though
that people get
like for yourself like i i from
following your page i feel like now you
you're more conservative like you did
are you know what i mean like you
is that is that a fair assessment like
are you like a republican are you like
you know libertarian or but i feel like
you're very you've moved more
conservative right yeah any of those
could do i mean i i just kind of think
for myself and do my own thing but if
you know i would say certain things i
think libertarians are right on certain
things republicans but yeah i lean more
right definitely like smaller government
more personal freedom and also i think
the republican party weirdly enough i
think they used to be really
close-minded in some ways they still are
but now it seems like you know these are
the people like trying to protect joe
rogan and dave chappelle even though
dave chappelle's not even conservative
so it seems like they're on the right
side of free speech and you know
preserving liberty so yeah that's that's
a fair secret well i don't know if
that's actually a fair characterization
because i feel like when you only have
two when you only have two major parties
okay so then it's like what room are you
supposed to go in like you don't agree
with everything in this room and you
don't agree with everything in that room
so when you go in a room i don't think
it's fair to be like well i'm in this
room so now this is the room that has
more
maybe
a couple of people in that room but i
don't think the room as a whole on
either side is a room that we that i
know i don't want to be in right now i'm
realizing well they used to say the
lesser of two evils and i think that's
such a good way to put it where it's
like you're picking which one you think
is slightly less but for example say
like big pharma like someone like neil
young he was making you know uh albums
about monsanto exposing the corruption
of monsanto years ago which is great i
think you should use your voice to talk
about agriculture or whatever but now
it's like left-wingers in many ways not
everybody but a lot of people who used
to be so critical of big corporations
big government big pharma you know now
they're almost trying to eliminate any
conversation around anybody challenging
it and it's not everybody there's a lot
of honest people like you know even like
russell brand types where they're kind
of challenging both sides but it does
seem to be like for whatever reason
recently that the right has been like no
no no we can challenge it we can
question it and the left has kind of
slid so i think it's cyclical i think at
certain points depending who the
president is who's pushing which policy
like if it's george bush doing it
republicans aren't going to go along
with it if it's obama if it's trump
people are going to go different ways
but recently it just seems like you know
when i was young and i was more liberal
leaning i was like you know this is
freedom i have free of expression they
don't care they're not like the
christians trying to shut me up but now
it's almost like it's almost flipped
where it's like the left is like they're
mad at the office and things that
everybody loved five years ago so that's
what i'm talking it's not everybody or
everybody's right everyone's wrong but i
have seen this kind of shift into
thinking that liberalism which by
definition means opening new ideas means
you have to be close to new ideas
um what i was saying earlier
on the lines of what you're saying right
now is like i feel like there's like
i feel like there's a stigma right now
that once you start
letting both sides talk and investigate
then you get this sort of like
conservative mark this conservative like
uh label right you know and i think
that's what happens with like rogan
where it's like
because he puts on
who he puts on all of a sudden that
means that okay he's a right-wing nut
right you know what i mean and i think
that
you know because to me i feel like when
you when you just have a two parties if
we had five parties right
i don't i think that because like
what's crazy right now is i i don't
think anybody is truly
republican or democrat in the in the
traditional sense because you could be
say
pro-life
and you also want
your gun right
you know what i mean i think that's a
real
feeling right i think it's like you know
i think you could be like i i don't like
big big pharma but at the same time i
want to you know let's do something for
our homeless uh you know so i i think
that
the the problem the pushback right now
is that i think i think a lot of people
are sitting in the middle like yeah i
kind of agree with some of the things
you're saying and i kind of agree with
some of the things they're saying but we
get put in this fight we get put in this
match where you have to pick a side
right and i i don't like that no that's
fair i think uh i've seen it from both
sides where i i didn't really think
about this much growing up because
people didn't act this way uh in my view
but you know they call it like the npc
character the non-playable character
like when you subscribe to one side or
the other you just kind of keep
repeating these five lines and you don't
challenge yourself where when i came out
in 2017-18
and my whole video was hey i didn't vote
for donald trump i voted green party
right in 2016. i've never voted
republican here's why i think the media
is exaggerating about what he's doing it
blew up because i did it in such a chill
way and i got so much backlash from the
left and then in 2021 you know when i
see trump running around the country
just selling vaccines i don't care that
he says he wants people to take him but
he stopped talking about you know all
this stuff we're dealing with and he
just kind of sounded like a pharmacy
commercial to me i'm like it's one thing
to sell your product but i'm like bro
you haven't said anything meaningful in
a year you sound like you work for
pfizer man i got that same backlash from
the right wing right and they're like
they started calling me a democrat
chinese
yeah
and then they're calling me russian bots
so i'm like wow it is true like you know
you agree with people on certain things
they're like we agree on 99 they're like
but what do you think about you know
these people playing sports and women's
sports they're like uh and they're like
we hate you so it's like if one of your
opinion disagrees with like the main
parties and that's really conditioning
right like you said one side other side
you get your news you get your news and
you fight each other and you don't even
realize that the truth is uh you know
that every policy that's more nuanced
it's it's way more nuanced and parties
are sold out both parties are you know
taking money from big banks big pharma
so there's there's certain things that
they're all passing these multi-billion
trillion dollar deals that nobody reads
where's that money going nobody knows
nobody cares so this idea that like
either side is flawless or they're
fighting so hard for us it's people got
to break that programming yeah i totally
agree with you and i and i feel like um
i don't yeah i mean just it's just
sometimes i wonder during an election
cycle
why even have
campaigning if it's just supposed to be
if you're
republican you vote for the republican
so to me it's like
it should just be when you go register
to vote that's your vote
you know what i'm saying the way it's
set up right now should be i'm a
registered democrat so therefore every
democrat on the on on the on the thing i
have to vote for them you know that's
that's the way that then you didn't you
could just you could just have a
cardboard cutout you could just have a
cardboard cutout you know on you know in
a pokemobile just like you know you're
on on a thing turning like this you know
what i mean and then we just go yay you
know it's like you know no guns no like
whatever the thing is that they want to
say you know what i mean and it's just
it's so
this idea of like breaking that away and
being like you know it sucks that like
you could be say a democrat like say you
were but but guess by the way that's
because you were younger you know and
when you're young you're always more
liberal right because mommy mommy and
daddy is the government paying for
everything right and then you're just
like you're like oh boom boom boom and
as soon as you graduate and get into the
world and you have to spend your money
on stuff right that's when you that's
when you start to go whoa whoa whoa hold
on a second right right i had that
awakening in california because i'm
listening to bernie sanders i know
nothing about taxes health care it
sounds great right i'm like man this guy
really cares i hit 25 26 now i'm
starting to pay for my own health
insurance in california they don't let
you opt out i couldn't afford it but
they forced me to pay and i was like
well i don't even have the money to pay
and they're like well then we're gonna
charge you with the penalty and i'm
thinking to myself i thought this was
free what's up everybody
let's talk about ritual we deserve to
know what we're putting in our bodies
and why especially when it comes to
something we take every single day like
vitamins ritual is clean vegan friendly
multivitamins and they're formulated
with high quality nutrients
uh it's everything that your body
actually needs and uses
look there's no sugars no gmos no major
allergens synthetic fillers artificial
colorants it's just all natural vitamins
i take vitamins every single day ritual
is great for this you know they have a
subscription plan so it comes to you
every month
i mean it's great
multivitamins to your door every month
with free shipping always you can start
hit the snooze or cancel your
subscription anytime and if you don't
love ritual within the first month
they'll refund your first order
get the key nutrients without the bs
rituals offering my listeners 10 off
during your first three months visit
ritual.com griffin to start your ritual
today that's ritual.com
griffin for 10 off during your first
three months
what's up y'all you know i'm on the road
a lot now back on the road uh you know
the world has opened up more and i'm
just sleeping in a lot of terrible
mattresses in these hotels so i'm
telling you i got a healing sleep
mattress i love it you'll love it they
got the sleep quiz you take it
everybody's body is unique and helix
knows that so they have several
different types of mattresses and models
to even choose from they have soft
medium firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot or even the helix plus
mattress for plus size folks
if you're a big big person they got a
mattress just for you i took the helix
sleep quiz and they matched me to the mo
to the mattress that's best for me
because i'm a side sleeper so when
you're a side sleeper you know you toss
and turn so it's got to be the right
type of firmness right type of softness
and i have it it's perfect
so if you're looking for a mattress take
that sleep quiz order your mattress they
match you and they send it to you helix
is awesome
don't just take it from me helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress in 2020 by gq and wired
magazine it comes to your door for free
you don't ever have to go to the
mattress store again you hear me and
that's really important just go to
healingsleep.com griffin take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
to the customized mattress that will
give you
the best sleep of your life
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up if you don't
like it they'll pick it up for free
but i'm telling you you're going to love
it helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com
griffin
you hear that you've been on the same
mattress for a long time it's time to
get a new mattress take it from me go to
helixsleep.com
griffin you know saying i thought this
was only for the rich and i'm not paying
all these things i register for an llc
in california you know under democrats
it's like thousands of dollars i'm like
what i thought i thought jeff bezos was
gonna pay for this you know so that woke
me up real quick and uh you know once
you start making money and employing
people i mean they're trying to take
thirty percent forty percent tens of
thousands of dollars
for what though am i helping like rogan
who talks about he's like if my tax
dollars were going to helping but
california is number one in the country
in poverty our homelessness is spiraling
out of control all the money they spend
they keep making it worse i would rather
keep my money and give 100 tips to every
waitress i see and you know give it out
to people that i trust and you know i i
i
mean
well this brings up a whole other
discussion that we can talk about i mean
it's just like i feel like we're over
taxed for sure so it's like you know so
it's like you had this business you know
you had this business so you you know so
you you every so you make a dollar right
you make a dollar and from this from and
that dollar is taxed right
from that dollar i have to pay pay my
employee from that dollar right
and they're taxed right on that same the
same dollar that i took money from and
paid them i've already got taxed on it
now they're getting taxed right okay
with that dollar and then they go and
buy something
with that same dollar and then it's
taxed again right so you just kind of go
like you know yeah property tax you buy
a house you sell a house you pay every
month everything's getting taxed on
every side all the time
yeah man it's like so i i get it i mean
it's like and then you you we would just
like we'd want to know where the money
goes and his pete helped but i but by
the way though
i do take exception to sometimes when
people talk smack about california when
you say these numbers about california
let's also remember we also have the
highest population in the entire country
with the best weather that's why all the
homes you know people that's why people
come here so that's why people come here
so there is that is part of it so it's
always skewed when people go man
california is the worst it's like yeah
because people say why do you live there
i'm like man it's the best it's really
in my opinion one of the best states you
got the mountains you got the ocean it's
just go skiing you can go surfing in the
same day right
i don't like to poo poo on it completely
but uh yeah the policy i guess it's like
you know they can't figure out what to
do about it on the taxes thing too a lot
of people think well you know this is
going to help these people in theory it
is but both sides of politics are so
corrupt every year it's called an
omnibus bill they get together and they
pass this multi-billion sometimes
trillion dollar bill that nobody even
has time to read like one time ted cruz
talked about it and he said 10 things
and he was explaining he's like this has
been on my desk for 24 hours and
everybody already signed it it's not
even physically possible to read what's
where's that money going so the
government unlike amazon and i'm not
saying amazon's perfect but it's like
the government takes our money every
year disperses it and there's zero
penalty for not doing well like if you
work on a show and you're not making
money eventually they're gonna cancel it
like the government can't get canceled
because they're constantly taking out
essentially just stealing other people's
money so the whole kind of business
model of it's corrupt but how perfect is
it the democrats fight with the
republicans i like trump i hate trump i
like biden i hate bi everyone's fighting
and no one even realizes that they're
probably both laughing hysterically
because it's like trillion dollar you
know tax bills that they get every year
throw it around and if they blow it all
it doesn't matter the next year they're
coming back to take take our money again
oh man it's so funny you said that
because i i've talked about just before
my podcast but i'm gonna talk about with
you it's like this is what i feel about
guns what you just said is like you know
as as either as either these two
political entities are fighting with
each other the person that's laughing
the most is the gun company
because they're like because my
assertion is why is that the only
technology you know in the same way that
they
that they held back electric cars for 35
years so so
the gut so the oil companies can make
money the oil companies like no no we
can't go electric right so you know if
you believe in that conspiracy that they
put the kibosh on that and i believe
that i i think that the electric car
electric car could have been 35 years
ago we could allow electric cars you
know but they made them look stupid that
whatever was happening that documentary
is great about it well i feel like
where's the uh non-lethal gun technology
i bet it's i bet it's sitting on a desk
someplace and they're like why it's
cheaper to shoot little pieces of metal
at each other and then like you and then
fight about that whereas whereas what
i'm saying is like if that's the only
thing available then yeah you know a kid
like that kid that went you know he got
got in you know uh he went and shot
people uh in in self-defense if he's
using if that's the only option then we
can fight about that but if there was
another option available if there was a
non-lethal technology available that you
know an electric gun per se then then
now you have an argument because now you
have like well you want you have a
lethal weapon in your hand and so the
laws could change things would be
different i'm just i'm just saying it's
like as we thought about this i don't
think we should fight we should be
calling for improvements we should be
calling for like don't take away the
guns but hey do they have to be lethal
they have like tasers and stuff but i
think in like to your point of
innovation and stuff it's easier to just
kind of gatekeep and ride what's hot now
so if oil's not fried that if if the
electric narrative is hot let's ride
that like if sugar's hot and it's making
a lot of money let's tell everybody fat
is is the problem and not sugar and
let's make the money off that let's you
know milk got milk like let's sell some
milk so when something's hot you know
there's a tend to be corruption because
and same with big pharma if you look at
the amount of pills like 50 years ago to
now it's working it's making money like
let's keep the gravy train going so i
think you know it's very it's a lot more
hard it's like with music if you hear a
song it's it's almost easier for a lot
of non-creative artists to just copy and
ride that wave as opposed to create the
new wave where someone like elon musk
you know to sit down and be like well
let me try to do this differently it's
way harder it's very rewarding clearly
if you do it but it's just it's just
easier to you know ride a previous wave
and just kind of like quash innovation
for your own financial benefit
man that's such a nuanced take i'm with
you 100
this is why i like you
you people listening right now this
ain't about politics because you know
people just hear things and they're just
going to attack you know the comments
are going to be full of like
and i'm just saying like what like that
is such a brilliant nuance take about
this i mean it's so true like yeah like
the got milk
you know like i saw one video about how
milk is made and i was out
you know what i mean like i i'm all oat
milk now i'm all right you know
i would drink almond milk but i'm like
alert sometimes i have an allergic
reality a reaction to almonds it's
something with my stomach anyway the
point is like
that's so true man and i feel like the
gun wave that's what we've been riding
on like i'm not gonna sit here and argue
about like i'm not trying to take your
gun away from you i'm not trying you
know what i mean and and and they get on
like i feel like a gun nut that's the
safest person have you ever met someone
who's like super into guns that person
knows they're so safe they're so like
they got it locked up they know
everything about it yeah the person i
want to have a gun
like a rogan or ted nugent with gunshots
like you know in my personal life it's
not like it's not my favorite hobby but
i understand where it's like if you know
governments in history have killed
hundreds of millions of people if your
population is armed you're better
against a foreign country or your
government where it's like it's just in
the like australia they took the guns
and then they're you know
enforcing even crazier policies so a lot
of people on the right are like well you
know this is why i like it to defend
myself if the police aren't there uh or
for your country to have more power
against the government on the milk thing
i just want to say real quick like
factory farming is disgusting you know
if you have a local farmer that's great
and even that there's nuance in that
where it's like yes everybody needs to
eat so they're mass producing on a big
scale but there's got to be a better way
to do this there is a better way to do
it but it's cheaper and easier to just
throw 10 000 cows in a small place kill
them feed them with gmos pump their meat
so it's bigger and then like dole it out
so like like the whole food industry is
like disgusting at this point but at the
same time i don't have to go hunt for
myself so i'm going to shut up about it
you know like it's like it's
convenience so there's curses and
blessings to to that whole argument as
well yeah it's just like when you talk
about like you know why aren't there
jobs here in the united states and these
jobs you know you know when they say
that the illegal immigrants come in or
or even legal immigrants come in and
they do these certain jobs on farms and
these kinds of things and then you know
we talk about like you know wages and
stuff like that you know people forget
that like okay well do you want your big
mac to be fifty dollars
because you know that's what it's going
to end up being and so people kind of
get silent about you know
that's why i'm writing a book and this
isn't like a plug for it because it's
not even done yet but i'm i'm using the
words
that's what it is i don't even know what
the name of it is yet so it's not even
for sale
the unentitled anomaly book guys look
out for it in what two maybe two years
the word racist sex is xenophobic and
stuff i'm kind of trying to tell people
why these are overused and not necessary
even to fight hate because say you talk
about the border like illegal
immigration or like work visas and stuff
if you just say racist what that means
is like you're bad i'm good i win the
conversation you hate everybody where i
i read you know that your mom's from
belize i'm part puerto rican it's not
like to throw out my hispanic card but
it's like yeah i don't hate my family
but in general it's like there's things
going on here first of all uh you have
uh corporations that are green lighting
cheaper wager right there they're green
lighting a bunch of people not because
they love everybody but because they
think that that will be cheaper and make
more money for them but there's a way to
have this conversation and show
compassion be like well i also
understand why people want to come to
this country economically etc and
we could get a lot done if people had
conversations and talked about it
without just throwing up these words or
saying like you're a bigot you're in it
like and and and it's like it reminds me
of like kindergarten it's you got 50
year olds acting like high schoolers and
i'm like wow this is nothing gets done
in this country because everybody's so
defensive everybody's constantly like
accusing people of stuff and i think uh
you know with comedy and and television
people are so sensitive like they tried
to cancel the michael scott episode
where he was being racially insensitive
to mindy kaling without understanding
that's what makes it funny is that he's
an ignorant character and he's right
being ignorant is the joke and if you go
to workaholics like none of the
characters are perfect everybody's
flawed and it's funny when they do dumb
stuff if everybody just says i like your
race i like your race there's no humor
in it there's no villain there's no good
person so i people have lost sense of
that's why so many movies and comedy is
so stale is because there's no climax
they've taken that out in their like
utopian idea but they're ruining
everything where it's like you have to
have an ignorant character in order to
in order to have some sort of punchline
yeah to highlight how stupid he is
that's what that was what the hell like
it's so dumb about that episode is he
was literally being reprimanded
michael scott character was being
reprimanded for how he is and he didn't
get it as a character right and that's
what the humor of it was right no
self-awareness he has no the no
self-awareness was the comedy in it man
don't even get me started on this man
you know the my problem with like sort
of like these like sensitive woke
social justice warrior types and first
of all let me say this we're all
sensitive i'm sensitive the things i
talk about or because of my sensitivity
you know so i don't mind being sensitive
my problem is is how it's weaponized my
problem is is how you know uh these woke
type people
they think they have the moral high
ground and they don't realize they're
being weaponized against their own best
interest right you know
and um
and it's so easy to weaponize them
that's what they don't see like someone
could just be like like i talk about
this on stage now too like jesse
smollette
he weaponized right the sensitive right
he said he was trying to distract
everybody from what was going on in his
like you know work he said how can i do
this and he did it by
i'm gay and i was attacked right and
then these people went oh i can't
believe that that happened and then they
all went on twitter and i have so many
liberal actor friends who were on
twitter like i can't believe we live in
a world where this happens oh my god
no investigation no due process no facts
nothing just his word then when it came
out that he was lying i'm like
where's your tweets
[Laughter]
where where is because and to me
those type of people should be outraged
when someone uses their sensitivity
against them
it's like when someone just claims
racism you know and then everybody jumps
on it you know when people claim sexism
and everybody jumps on it without
any sort of like facts or knowledge or
anything that's dangerous and they don't
realize
that they're being weaponized it's like
it's like we don't talk about obesity in
this country we don't talk about it we
don't show how
dangerous this is like the leading cause
of death is heart disease and one of the
leading causes of heart disease is
obesity
and we don't even discuss it we talk
about body positivity right now that's
those woke people being weaponized
against their own best interest that's
how i feel about it and opioids and
fentanyl too is sending our life
expectancy backwards and you know but
you can't question big pharma even
though i think opioids killed over a
million people on the note of like
weaponizing people against their own
self-interest there's uh you know i
wanted to say for the left you have lgbt
black lesbian like minority these are
things that people are rightfully
sensitive about so they use that and
they know that they can push their
agenda through these things and put up a
shield against anybody pushing back on
the right wing how they do it is they
use the pro-america thing you know
saying say the iraq war it's like oh you
must be a terrorist if you don't agree
with this oh you must not you must hate
the country and both sides they've
tapped into if you want to trick the
right wing give them somebody that talks
like them who will push the pro-america
angle to what they're doing if you want
to give the left-wing do it through a
minority or lgbt group and these groups
have gotten so in the mainstream not in
real life but have gotten out of control
because that they've realized this and
now they get away with it they're like
dude we can just push this do whatever
we want say whatever we want and if
anybody questions our political
narrative uh we're just gonna call him a
racist a sexist a homophobic in jesse
smallett's case i i checked out his uh
you know just like wiki just seeing
stuff it's like he's gay and i believe
he's half black and half jewish so
technically he could call you an
anti-semite race right right he's got
the trifecta he's got the trifecta so he
was walking like his [ __ ] don't stink
you know he's he's like no one can i
just feel like i felt like i was really
disappointed because i felt like you
know all these people that i know
personally who were like on twitter like
just like you know speaking out against
this i thought man you don't realize how
he took advantage of you right
emotionally he emotionally uh
manipulated you and that's what these
woke people don't understand they're
being emotionally manipulated right
and and they're weaponized you know and
it's just like i think that's dangerous
you know what i mean i just i just think
it's dangerous with comedy too it's like
not only do you need a climax and a good
and bad character and like somebody to
look at and laugh at and be like oh he's
the goofy one but also if you listen to
anybody whether it be like the most
chill comedian who doesn't curse or like
the craziest one who says the craziest
stuff what do you talk about in this
world you talk about race you talk about
religion you talk about your wife you
talk about gender you talk about
different countries you talk about
experiences you talk about ignorant
people you're ignorant they're ignorant
you made a mistake they made them sick
that's what comedy is there is no
comedian that goes up there and just
says like you know i had a great day
like someone smiled at me i smiled at
them they used my pronouns i used their
pronouns and believe it or not like
nothing happened it's like there's no
joke to that i think the closest was
like crystalia when he was like i'm the
only comedian that didn't have a bad
childhood he's like my childhood was
great he's like so i don't know what
everyone else is talking about it was
funny um but you know there really is no
punch line without the dynamics of the
world and it's not real it's like
telling kids oh you know we're going to
defeat childhood bullying they used to
say that all the time and then you grow
up and you're like man adults are even
bigger bullies than kids so how are you
going to stop the kids from bullying
when you're 55 and you you're not even
stopping bullying like it's just a fake
signal
i know it's it's been more challenging
to do comedy just because i just think
that people forget things like
being facetious that's part of comedy
you know uh you know uh
um like figures of speech people have
forgot like it's like people you know
they take everything so literal then
attack your character but it's like when
i say to you if i go like yo man give me
a minute okay uh what does give me a
minute mean right does it mean
a minute yeah no when i say give me a
minute it means uh i'm gonna need some
time that's what that you know give me a
second you know nobody goes these people
that get sensitive they're like one
wow you don't respect time you don't
respect my you know you know it's like
no that's just a figure of speech you
know i've used this example before too
it's like if i if you and i are driving
down the street and we're running late
and then i we hit some traffic some
really bad traffic we don't know what's
going on and i turn to you and i say man
there better be a dead baby up here like
do i want a dead baby up there yeah
it's just a way of saying i hope
something really super important is
going on because we're going to be late
but people take your words and they they
forget
that kind of stuff they just take your
words and they turn you into well this
guy's condoning violence against babies
this guy is uh you know this guy's a
baby hater you know or whatever whatever
they're going to turn it into and that's
what happens in comedy you know you
forget that like yeah like you said
there's got to be a punch line there's
always going to be a butt of the joke
right all right there's always going to
be a butt of the joke
how hard it slapped
is
what people's sensitivity is tapping
into
i think at the same time that they're
trying to cancel and stuff it's made
people even bigger superstars because
i'm sure a lot of hollywood and a lot of
mainstream comedy like everybody's
afraid to say anything i mean everybody
has twitter you could watch what
everyone said in 2012 this was a time
when people were looser and you know
more risky but now everyone's kind of
playing it safe so the people that are
winning big are really the people that
aren't playing is safe you know you have
a lot of new comedians who have grown
their youtube channel out of kind of
joking about wolf culture uh you know
people like chappelle and uh joe rogan
have exploded off of that so there is
room to grow um
and i think it's way more popular like
it's this minority of like executives
and people even in like san francisco
new york city like they don't realize
that a lot of the country's not on their
page and even people who vote in similar
fashions like i have a lot of friends
that lean left like everybody's kind of
like if you're a real person in the real
world and you have a family a job
whatever you don't have time to worry
about things that people said like
halfway across the country like this
over sensitivity it's really just
showing like how great it is for a lot
of people because back in the day you
had to hunt you had to like do things or
else you weren't eating at night and now
it's like i could blog and get ubereats
on my phone and like complain about
rudolph or something like i have that
time that's a lot of time you got to do
that
well i mean i feel like like you were
even like how we were saying earlier
about just like you know um you know
like
you know how either side
they have their own version because
first of all i always say woke woke
isn't just for the left man
people use woke when they don't have
they don't have the words to articulate
their position right then they say woke
you know either side could be woke like
even you look at the january 6
they think they're woke you know what i
mean we're doing this because we're woke
and then the other side is like against
it because they're i mean you know what
i mean so it doesn't you know you know
either side they use this stuff against
the other side and for comedy for
anything even in politics man like
there's this great youtube clip of trump
at a rally
and i never forget it because he was
sitting there and he was going you know
they told me to say drain the swamp
and i didn't like it at first
he's saying this
like he's saying this to his fans his
his supporters he's letting them know
hey
i fooled you yeah you know you know i i
they got me in office because we said
these things i didn't agree he's
basically going i didn't agree with it
really but hey they said it was gonna
work and i thought to myself wow
you know it's one of the things i
actually really liked about the guy was
like you know he was so unconventional
you know
you know he
he's the one like he'll be like well
you're fat ted cruz yeah you know what i
mean and you're like
you're like he is putting on the pound
cheater
you know it just it was so like outside
of the like the political speak norm you
know that that was you know i don't know
if necessarily that should be in office
you know what i mean well think about
like me correct what is it it's like
scripted right it's really like fake so
so all yeah technicians are just telling
you what you want to hear it provides
some sense of comfort but it's not real
like it's not they don't have it all
under control they're just pretending so
he kind of broke through and pushed the
boundaries but the crazy part is what
you're saying and what i started
figuring out over the couple years where
i was like was he really put like he was
pushing the boundaries of speech of what
to say but was did he mean it or was it
like a campaign so like he had really
smart populists like you know bannon
types that are writing this stuff for
him and he's saying it that's what it
starts to seem like to me because now
that it's all said and done you know
when you're going out of office you can
do a lot in the last couple of months
you could pardon people you know you
could pardon snowden or assange things
that a lot of people on both sides
wanted he didn't really do any of that
so it's starting to seem like like you
said is that he played this role of i'm
this guy who's outside the system and
he's a funnier better you know actor but
was that really who he was you know i'm
starting to question that as well
because he he'll go up there and be like
yeah yeah like this like someone told me
to say this and like you know i was like
you sure it's like okay so it was like
this whole brand for you it wasn't like
a real spirit we all thought it was a
spirit that's the thought i got from
that that um that press conference that
like that rally right he was saying like
you know and and again the people in the
audience were kind of like wait wait
what
what are you what like because i think
and i think he also
kind of got off on being like i did it i
got it
you know what i mean because like you
know it's just like um citizen kane man
you know i don't know if you know about
that movie citizen kane but like but
there's a thing about like
once you become super wealthy what's
next
it's like power and then what what then
what's with power you also want the love
of the people right now it's like
it's money's not everything to people
you know and so i mean
it's crazy that he went from being like
hanging out with rappers and people you
know
people really loving him
i watched his show you're fired and all
that he went from that figure to then
like through the political process when
obama was in office and the whole like
birther thing the whole like you know
your birth certificate and all that and
all that stuff and then all of a sudden
he was just running for office you know
what i mean his twitter was hilarious he
used to talk like he'd be like to robert
pattinson he was like dump your
girlfriend she's playing you and you're
like yeah why is donald trump like
weighing in on celebrity marriages his
character was hilarious but uh i think
in general too like for me i did a lot
more research over the years where what
was appealing to him is like yo i'm so
rich i don't need anybody's money but
then you kind of look on record and he
took money from pfizer bank of america
and you're like i thought you you know
like he played this role of like i don't
need to be this and i think when push
came to shove he ended up you know like
i don't know how hard it is to be
president but it seems like they all end
up being controlled or they all you know
they all end up disappointing and
falling short to what everybody expected
and maybe that's you know maybe that's
the the campaign like i'm obama change
is going to come i'm trump change is
going to come i'm inviting something
about change i forgot my line you know
like and then everyone's like people
keep going back and forth and they don't
know how you know what's crazy is like
for biden it was like it's even worse
than that for biden it's just i'm not
that guy right right
right at least obama and trump has a
swag yeah he look tell us about you he's
like i'm not trump like that should have
been the campaign the campaign should
have been i'm not trump and then we were
like yeah he's not trump like and now
we're like yo so who are you and then
now everybody's like i don't know i
don't know if i like you either but i
know what you mean man it's so it's so
strange i mean like i'm not you know i
think that like you know uh when you
said about like he said i'm rich enough
no no he's not rich enough no one's rich
enough that's the whole idea like i
think that these people are it's like
there's always more money
and when you're doing a billion dollar
campaign like you're not going to spend
a billion dollars for your money i think
the closest person who came to actually
using their own money was bloomberg you
know he doled out a lot of money and
just got destroyed like that you know he
spent i don't know how much he spent
homeboy two from um from the election
when clinton won the reason clinton won
uh bro
uh yeah ross pearl i think he spent a
bunch of his own money too right i mean
you know the clinton should send him a
gift basket every single year saying
thank you for splitting up the
republican party because he couldn't
never would have won if it was no ross
perot what's his face would have
dominated you know what i mean but i
heard he was like
i didn't listen to his stuff i was a
little too young but uh you know i guess
i guess he has some good ideas but not
enough clout you know it's it's tough to
break that two-party system all the air
time they give the debates like it's
almost impossible yeah man it's
impossible but that's what i'm saying
about like you know if you had other
parties you know i mean it's like it's
funny like when you look at like bernie
you know bernie's talking about like you
know helping people and giving people
money and everybody's getting on this
case then the pandemic comes and the
government gives people money and then
he's like didn't isn't this what i said
we should
now it's okay you're right now trump
turned into like a bernie sanders and
people get mad on the right when i say
that but it's like he did bernie's
policy and aoc's policy of universal
basic income a year ago they said oh
that's socialist i don't want to do that
you know and america will never be
socialist and then they're throwing out
trump bucks to everybody well now
there's a virus so now we're going to do
socialism and the funny part is the left
wing won't give him credit and the right
wing won't admit it they're like you
think trump's a socialist i'm like bro
he shut the country down and and printed
out a thousand bucks for everybody like
that's a policy straight out of bernie's
playbook but
people are so into the character hating
or loving
that they that they uh that they don't
pay attention to like basic yeah
yeah once you label it too like once you
label it something so it's like so so
that's a stigma on both sides you know
and and this was like to get it back to
what i was saying earlier about you
is like once you're labeled like so you
know you've probably been labeled
conservative yeah you know yeah i've
been labeled worse than that that's that
would be a kind of statement but you
know what i mean you know what i mean so
once you like label conservatives so
like sometimes when i'm even when i'm
looking at your videos i get a sense of
like i get a sense of like i think of it
that way too sometimes you know i think
it's like he's very conservative and so
let me hear his conservative point of
view yeah like i realized you know it's
really not that you know what i mean
it's it's not that but once you once
that's in your head of like okay that
person's a liberal so then everything
they say is going to be about liberal
stuff
that person is labeled conservative and
so i think that's the dangerous part how
do you think we could break that
i think you're an honest person i want
to say real quick like you know it
starts with you so it's like if you you
know ignore what everybody says and be
like i'm gonna i respect myself enough
to hear people out and see where what i
feel about it uh roseanne went on jimmy
kimmel years ago this was during the
trump hour and she said what happened
you used to be a liberal and her answer
was perfect she said i'm the same person
i was a couple years ago you all changed
and went so far out that you lost
everybody and that's what she said about
the left she was like i'm exactly who i
was three four years ago you guys are
the ones that went extreme and now
you're losing the whole country because
you're doing too much and i feel like
that's very similar to what happened um
but the media is very dishonest as far
as like you know say robert malone he
i'm not going to say he invented because
they challenged that but he helped
develop mrna technology he was one of
the guys in on it he took the vaccine
that he pretty much helped develop at an
earlier stage of getting this technology
along they call him a right-wing
anti-baxter conspiracy theorist it's
like not only is he not an anti-vaxxer
he's been vaccinated he got this vaccine
and he also helped develop the
technology so they're willing to throw
these labels on people so loosely that
people buy into it to to block it out
how do we get through it i think people
need to respect themselves enough to
listen like i'm not afraid of listening
to somebody on the left or the right but
half of the trap is they try to demonize
and it happens on both sides to people
that people consider extreme or fringe
where it's like yo uh i don't want to
listen to that person they're too far
left they're too far right you got to
respect yourself enough to be
intelligent be like i can make my own
informed decision if i listen to joe
rogan and rachel maddow and what you
start to realize is the people they
demonize the most are usually the most
even keeled and the people that they
promote are usually the ones that are
the most not only extreme extreme yeah
yeah extreme and ready to censor like
neil young i like his music but it's
like dude i would love to see you sit
down and have a conversation with joe
rogan or a doctor because you know i
think that there's probably some points
you have that are great but a lot of
these people they like even like howard
stern and sasha barack owen people that
i used to love for some reason they're
just like shut it down shut it out and
and that's the opposite of how to learn
and and grow is like
blocking it out so not buying the labels
you know everybody's falsely labeled at
this point nothing none of these labels
matter what matters is like the content
of their their their argument and here
hear everybody out that's how to get
through it i think i wish they would
just like you know like sometimes when i
think about cnn and fox i wish they i
wish they would just just call it what
it is just be like this is the right
wing echo chamber and this is the left
wing echo chamber because i actually
have a lot of friends that like i hear
them talk and i just go man
like this is
like you you just want to hear what you
want to hear like you just you just want
to hear things you agree with and people
i honestly think people are just
comfortable with that sometimes like
it's comfortable just to be like
oh yeah you know i want to be on that
you know i believe in this and that's it
and they don't even want to listen or
hear anything because it's just it's too
much it messes with their their paradigm
you know what i mean especially in the
entertainment world but to be fair in
tech in business like a lot of these big
corporations are going full in on the
woke left-wing agenda so i mean it's a
serious risk if you decide that you're
in the middle and bipartisan and you
think that some of it's nonsense you're
risking now like i've seen some of my
friends work emails he worked in new
york it's insane how crazy these people
are i wouldn't last for two seconds so
it's like do i want to lose family do i
want to lose friends do i want to lose
my job do i want to lose this new show
you know it it comes at a huge social
cost to be even healed and in the middle
now like it's not like
just being common sense and like dave
chappelle he's one of the most if not
the most beloved comedian of this era i
mean patton oswalt is apologizing for
standing next to him it's like bro
you know like you can't even be friends
with your friend that's how far you've
fallen because you're afraid of backlash
like that's that's not good
yeah it is pretty it is pretty uh or how
about even just being like
you know how about this too how about
just being like okay you go
all right chappelle
uh i liked this one special
it's also okay to be like
hey even as a comedian artistically to
be like
i don't know if you you had it in this
last one
this seemed angry it seemed too much it
seemed like like why still talk about
this right i think that's also okay a
point to have but i'm not demonizing the
guy right you know what i mean i'm
saying like there's an artist like can i
look at it just artistically and be like
this wasn't my favorite and it's the
reason why to me the backlash was so
heavy is because it wasn't as funny like
if it was more funny with the same
subjects i think people would be like
it's hard to say ah when you when you
hit somebody with a really good joke
that makes a solid point it's hard to
like argue with that because you're just
like ah you got me
he didn't have those moments in this one
and i think that it was like you know
but again you know he's still he's a
brilliant dude like i wish i wish that
special was a podcast i wish the things
he was talking about was like on the
dave chappelle show that he could sit
like like sean hannity and just you know
just like spew his stuff so you could be
like ooh
ooh instead of this
this um expectation that this is
supposed to be entertaining and i'm
supposed to laugh whereas like there's a
thing about him was like hey i'm
actually making a point here that i want
you to hear right and so the the the
ratio of like comedy
point where is that ratio that you feel
comfortable and i think that that's last
special the spectrum was not a
comfortable it wasn't a comfortable
percentage and that's why there's this
sort of backlash right i think your
perspective is the same reason i
actually turned it off for different
reasons i wasn't mad at him but it i
feel like my thought of it is you know
he's caught in the middle right now he
is not a hateful person he doesn't hate
transgenders he doesn't hate anybody um
but he's a sensitive person so he's
experiencing all this backlash so i
think that podcast or rather comedy
special he was trying to defend himself
but this is the unfortunate reality i
think of canceled culture is you want to
stand in the truth you want to be honest
to yourself and do what's right
regardless of who you know he's caving
to them in my like they think he's not
doing enough i think he's doing too much
to appease them to the point where like
you said i mean there's not that many
good jokes because he looks visibly like
upset you know i feel bad for him
because it's like he looks down and he's
like it wasn't like this euphoric
feeling of like yo this guy's the goat
like it was like yo i gotta take a break
like they're really wearing on him
that's why certain people say i don't i
don't read the same way yeah
and i feel i feel bad because i wish he
would stand up there and be like i'm not
a hateful person i don't you know like i
you know this is this is bs and then
just done jokes versus like a whole
backpedaling backpedaling and now he's
gonna like go off and be like he's he's
a sensitive guy and they got to him by
being such bullies i think
yeah they bullied him they 100 they
bullied him you know and he was trying
to make reference to that you know and i
i think so i i think he made some solid
points in this special right just to me
it wasn't
it wasn't as entertaining as he's been
in the past and i think that and when
and once that entertainment level
dropped that meant that was like the
sign for all those people to be like aha
you know and then he was just stuck in
this like oh man and so i i felt for him
too in terms of like you know you know
but at the same time i
go we don't all get the opportunity to
make our points over and over again at
20 million dollars a pop right
you know you know what i'm saying so at
the same time too kudos to you bro
he'll get it
so it's like you know it is it is what
it is man so
um well dude we've been like this has
been like you know i i feel like i got
to get you on again another time and you
know just yeah just come in i'll come in
person or something next time yeah you
got to come in person because i got to
get you on the singing mic and i know
everybody's going to want to see that
you know what i mean i might i got my
harmonica somewhere here too maybe i'll
bring my harmonica do a little harmonica
oh yeah
just what i'm saying
amazon copy yourself one
oh man you just that's that's a
nightmare um
that's great
yeah
don't come in bro we got a noise i know
i'm my neighborhood he's like yeah my
neighbors ain't gonna hear you talking
about harmonica playing no no you think
i live in something like you know you
think i live in an urban neighborhood
i'm just i'm just as bougie as you what
you talking about no no well that's
where people complain the most you know
sometimes yeah yeah that's
right
i was going to say enclosed because i
wanted to make a i just remember
something i i love this point you're
making about like when you're in the
middle you're in a tougher spot i
totally agree with you i do feel like i
have like a common sense approach and i
think people are like even killing all
this kind of stuff that's not exciting
you know it's like it's more exciting to
be like a left-wing nut or right-wing
nut it's just more exciting it's just
more like you know and my last thing is
like my problem with like the news like
first it's like here's the thing
when you look at like say fox news and
people get on all the liberals they love
crapping on fox news right
to me personally the actual news like
when they're doing the news yeah i think
they're okay
you know
now they've become the most like
balanced you know outside of everybody's
opinion it's like they'll they do a
better job of being somewhat balanced
and i don't get my news from there but
like they're more reasonable at this
point i believe but i'm talking about
that section that is actually the news
right
the problem is the other stuff
it's set up where it looks the same
true when sean hannity is sitting at a
table
like the other news people with the with
the pictures right here and he's sitting
there and he's presenting it as if this
is the news
that's my problem because i don't mind
hey have your kooky opinions have your
clearly agenda-driven like you know i'm
for whatever i don't like that it's
entertaining it's very entertaining but
like when you put that next to
when they're doing the actual news and
it looks the same that's hard for people
to like right to it to have that
adjustment in their head like oh okay so
this is the news okay now this is an
opinion show
they uh they teach that in journalism
school too like the uh you know the
manipulation of that of how they're
doing opinion shows in the same form as
the news
yeah and i don't i don't even have a
cable television but what i find is like
like you're talking about the whole
world there's millions of opinions
millions of people's millions of ideas
like the box of fox news like there's it
just seems like very cyclical to me you
know they talk about the same stuff all
the time and even on there like i'm not
gonna out people or anything i'm not
like that but like i have a lot of peers
in this space and what i find is like i
don't really play the games they play
like i'm i i do my own thing but when
you go to certain events and stuff like
these people are so used to just being
clapped by the right wing audience that
they a lot of them are like intellectual
featherweights they haven't thought in
five years they're just saying that
mickey mouse wears a dress this person
does this you know i'm saying the m m's
are gay or something like and it's like
i get what they're saying and like
sometimes i agree with them but it's
almost just like i'm yelling at the
liberal and they they like get the
makeup done yell at the liberal off the
screen over here yeah and they haven't
thought they're not they're not doing
this like uh you know mind-blowing
analysis like i'm not i say i do but you
know i'm like really doing my research
they don't do that they just yell
opinions for five minutes and give yeah
and then
and then the rest of the network gets a
bad rap on both sides because it's the
same thing on cnn msnbc like rachel
maddow and sean hannity they're the same
person
you know they're just coming from
different angles but they even got the
same haircut you know what i mean like
like like how can you even tell the
difference you know you know what i mean
it's like so i don't know but anyways
man i i appreciate you um everybody make
sure you check out you know all of uh
you know his stuff uh i have this i have
the instagram up right now you can find
him at dream r
dream rare on
on instagram
um so check him out i'll have all your
information i need you to send me all
your information websites yeah no
problem all that kind of stuff just like
i put it in the description i'll come to
your spot not not now i'm not pulling up
now but i'll come to your spot i'm
bringing the harmonica i'm going to test
please i'm going to test the
neighborhood see how she is i'm going to
bring up i'm going to bring a bike with
a bell on it and i'm going to just bang
it real loud and if nobody complains you
know i really gotta i really got to
stress test the neighborhood trust me
it's gonna be
i'm gonna get a phone call they're gonna
be like
there's a hippie with a bell and a
harmonica outside can you please can you
please you know my rent my rental
agreement is gonna happen
when i be like in l.a i move from like
crackheads everywhere to like literally
a lady snitching on me i pulled up in a
moving thing but and she was in the
tesla i guess we looked too sketchy in
our moving truck she's snitching on me
and i was like all right i made it i'm
finally in the neighborhood where old
ladies are are snitching on me like i'm
this
around
but anyways man i really appreciate you
being on and uh thanks for being here
and you know i will talk to you very
soon and uh what like i say everybody
this has been an anomaly and thank you
for being on roofing with griff of
course my pleasure